no hubo sorpresa ni milagro japonés en
este partido entre los nipones y a
Croacia fue la experiencia finalmente de
los croatas la que salió a relucir en
este partido que terminó finalmente
definiéndose desde los tiros de punto
penal un partido bastante equilibrado
entre ambos equipos con Los japoneses
que abrieron por primera vez el marcador
en este mundial un gol que vino sobre el
minuto 44 de madera sin embargo los
croatas respondieron ya sobre la hora de
juego con un cabezazo de perisich que
gonda no tuvo como atajar los dos
equipos subieron oportunidades cada uno
de poderse adelantar de poder conseguir
la victoria pero finalmente el partido
se fue ya a prolongaciones en la primera
parte fue mitoma quien tuvo la
posibilidad de marcar para Los japoneses
y en el segunda parte de esas
prolongaciones fue Mayer sin embargo ya
el partido se fue entonces a los penales
y ahí pues fue la gran desilusión de Los
japoneses que cobraron muy mal desde lo
del tiro desde el punto de tiro penal y
también pues estuvo muy bien al iva el
guardameta croata quien atajó tres de
esos penales y de esta manera pues
acroacia se clasifica a los cuartos de
final por tercera vez